[Musique]
dans les mots d'une personne célèbre oui
ça commence c'est tam tam canada si vous
posez la question là sur le web vous
attendiez ça commence tu oui c'est
commencer tomtom canada en direct de
montréal sur ces images de l'ouest
canadien
nous vous accueillons en ce beau
vendredi si l e il sait comment le ciel
cela a beaucoup changé depuis le sud
depuis ce matin ça va beaucoup plus mais
là c'est un soleil est joué moi je suis
ces gens chez moi ouais moi je sorte
septième au moment de l'orage
ah bon il ya eu un orage sa tombe est
épié tout coup tout était fini bon alors
autour de la table on a des gens qu'on
n'a pas vue depuis un bon bout de temps
alice chantal jon hamm est avec nous
bonjour à l'egypte cinq jours stéphane
paloma martinez a décidé de venir faire
un tour c'est parce que je ne veux pas
venir parce que c'est vrai que faire
deux émissions d'affilée la vôtre et
dans deux heures à peu près dans une
heure seulement seulement de l'énergie a
vraiment beaucoup d'énergie je sais j'ai
fait la semaine dernière d'une autre
émission
et puis c'est un cadeau qui m'a coûté
fatiguer un peu mais on aime ça
fantastique
et puis ma collègue de toutes les
guerres et toute l'année tous les
combats marie-jo batterie voix l'alberta
lorsque vous disiez ça parce qu'on l'a
très bien ça je pense au fait des années
que nous avons travaillé ensemble maryse
c'est sûr chacune chacun de séjour et de
graver la même moi pour toujours
j'espère que ce sont de bons souvenirs
écoutez les femmes voici je vous propose
la vidéo
oui l'homme oui moi aussi je vous
propose la vidéo 5 images comme les
internautes vous n'avez aucune idée du
sujet je vous demande de crier dès que
vous pensez que vous êtes sur la piste
je vous montre ses cinq images c'est pas
moi qu'il fait c'est la régie grâce à
l'ériger on peut tout faire
voici premières images à la plage c'est
beau ça fait rêver brésil
peut-être ouais comme ensemble tous
ensemble
non une mégalopole comme ça ça ressemble
au brise et le pavage pensez vous where
you
ouais vous pourriez sur la bonne piste
je dirais ouais ouais ça reste un chien
la forêt qu'il fallait voilà on va
essayer de savoir qui dit vrai si c'est
vrai que quand ça brûle c'est parce que
c'est normal ou quand ça brûle c'est
parce que c'est anormal comme le disait
certain nombre de politiciens
j'allais dire des ne nous c'est pas si
je voulais dire ça très nombreux
policiers discutaient à m'exprimer
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de ça avec une invitée qui
connaît le monde le débat
environnemental et de débats politiques
sur le terrain au brésil et tous à vue
du canada d'accord lorsque c'est
toujours ce que j'adore faire avec vous
en amenant le canada dans ce débat là en
vous parlant des forêts canadiennes
également maître de peu de peser les
forêts l'amazone y peser les forêts du
canada voir ce qui en ressort beaucoup
de bois j'en suis sûr
et beaucoup de feux de forêt on a ça en
commun alors premier tour de la grosse
boule action aux actions voilà alors
deux boutons qui brille un peu la main
toi même tu pour bien appréhender le
monde présente la question à l'écran
pendant que je trouve mon préambule
disons que on a perdu beaucoup de forêts
beaucoup d'un espace sauvage depuis un
certain nombre d'années par exemple de
1993 à 2009
il ya une enquête et fait en australie
et qui dit qu' on a perdu l'équivalent
d'un grand pays dans le monde depuis
c'est durant ces dernières années la
superficie à lorsque c'est la superficie
d'afrique du sud qu'on a perdus durant
ces années la superficie du mexique
paloma vous êtes d'origine mexicaine
fait la même c'est le même pourcentage
territoire les mêmes territoires que le
québec donc deux millions de kilomètres
carrés c'est grand est-ce que c'est là
qu'on a perdu en forêt sauvage dans le
monde
ou est-ce que c'est l'équivalent la
superficie du québec donc du mexique
moi je fais d'habitude je réponds
toujours à la fin mais là je suis
peut-être de répondre au début vu qu'il
ya le mexique et le québec qui sont de
la même grandeur pour être pas être la
réponse était c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose
ouais ouais c'est très peu alors jeune
fille paloma et je veux dire par des
proches de la question
non mais j'aime bien parlement parce que
le disait que le mexique est lé québec
était de la même travers je vais aller
avec appétit
afin que je pars pas et puis du côté moi
aussi j'irai avec l'afrique du sud
ah d'accord lundi j'imagine c'est plus
vaste ouais je veux dire par exemple la
bonne réponse et elle québec où le mec
sait qu'il y en aurait deux personnes
qui est qu'ils ne perdraient pas leur
vin bull dans son premier jeu démission
est aujourd'hui qui a répondu l'inde
vous perdez tous vont bouffer tout cela
est bien posé des questions à laquelle
j'ai une job mais j'ai jamais de réponse
mais c'est trois millions deux cent
quatre-vingt sept mille kilomètres
carrés 3 millions voilà ce qu'elle aime
exagérer quand même assez grave
voilà alors j'ai répondu à votre
question oui je me doutais que j'allais
poser cette question j'ai fait mes
recherches mais alors on est prêts pour
notre entrevue avec notre spécialiste
des questions environnementales et élève
avocate en droit environnementaux elle
travaille actuellement au département
des sciences juridiques de l'université
du québec à montréal donc non loin d'ici
à l'uqam
comme on l'appelle alors alexandra
déboule ski bonjour bonjour je devrais
dire m vous êtes avocate vous êtes
diplômé vous avez le certificat pour
pratiquer à au brésil
et vous vous êtes en train d'essayer de
parfaire vous d'obtenir le certificat
comment la police manon le baril
une façon générale comme la sociologie
du droit les droits populaires les
droits seulement va pas au brésil en ce
moment
alors on a tous entendu depuis une
semaine le débat entre le président de
la france et le nouveau président
brésilienne qui était au pouvoir depuis
le 1er janvier dernier il on dirait
qu'ils s'entendent pas sur la même
version des faits est aussi il faut dire
qu'il ya des différences de points de
vue entre ce que les 10 les statistiques
officielles du gouvernement brésilien
est ce que dit le grand leader brésilien
alors on sait plus à quelle un ou deux
branches et non mais la part où on prend
ça aujourd'hui par où on essaie de vous
professeurs dont vous êtes capable de
nous amener tranquillement vers la
vérité j'espère alors comment on espère
on espère tout le temps encore se fier à
la science
étant donné que c'est la part à m
j'imagine en ce moment encore les plus
fiables
mais malgré seulement bon son à l'eau il
fait partie d'un certain groupes
idéologiques politiques au brésil que
sait il si beaucoup à une jambe
la franche sur les paies un peu comment
je peux dire dirigé selon leurs intérêts
politiques alors qu'ils sont incertains
et les organismes étatiques au brésil
son prêt vient de lancer moment pour
dire on alloue alimentation à
significative de feu en amazonie c'est
un club historique au brésil ça commence
pas avec mon scénario il faut être juste
vote ferment
mr qu'est ce qui arrive en ce moment
c'est que les feux de forêt font partie
d'une virage brésil à l' express droite
mais aussi parce que les propriétaires
fonciers au brésil se sont autorisés 1
parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
questions et cinq salles ne sont pas
molli forêt par les gouvernements parce
que les gouvernements reconnus pour un
genre de développement qui marchandises
où la forêt est en même temps bon son
ado et sa campagne électorale
promesse de campagne je me disais les
propos qui vont plus avoir les mêmes
chances de forêt dans mon gouvernement
pendant le gouvernement une fois que
tous les acteurs ensemble donc on
s'attendait gouvernement n'empêche on il
faut de droits humains de droits des
peuples autochtones
mais ce que c'est que ça sorte en fait
moins de cadres de la normale
c'était bon scénario en ce moment il est
vraiment à tomber pour faire quelque
chose que ça farte tient aux brésiliens
ont peux vous promettre une garantie de
son vivant de la planète alors la
polémique il aime polémiques et les
choses il aime faire des speechs des à
l'option de discours est très malin et
responsables sans aucun fondement
politique c'est les ong qui ont mis le
feu sur l'amazonie 1 il ya quinze ans
cependant le zonage à l'option 25 parce
qu'ils ont érigés en choriste un coin
pour les complexes d argent mais en même
temps il y à une partie des
propriétaires fonciers en amazonie qui
est un des grands intérêts pour que les
faux choix très répandu parce que c'est
la façon la plus chère de préparer le
sucre le lait les éleveurs ont défoncé
c'est pas quelque chose de très
difficile
devant ce qui est parfois si la suisse
est difficile de dun suis la personne la
folie avec savanna plein de questions
pour vous alors commencer par maryse oui
parce que moi je passais en ce moment on
dit beaucoup que la chine qui ne veut
pas ce qui ne peut pas s'approvisionner
parce qu'elle est en conflit avec les
états unis va chercher du soja et du
boeuf du brésil ça met une grosse
pression et on pense aussi au fait que
dilma rousseff et d'où la da silva était
moins enclin peut-être à faire ça avant
parce qu'on dit que l'oeil pics et plus
important cette année cette
déforestation qu'avant oui
il faut comme nouvelle il a signé la
pole dance
miaou en 2003 donc moi très important
qui s'appelle élèves au brésilien pour
un que les présidents fois élu il se
dirigeait la population il là il faisait
un compromis avec le capital financier
en fait de dire écoutez une personne
d'audience de gauche
merde je veux h mais les compromis qu'on
a avec les grandes antilles nationale
avec les quatre falcon pour les
mouvements sociaux
ça faisait quelque chose de différent
les finalement une transformation plus
profond dans un pays extrêmement inégale
ce traitement raciste et qui n'est pas
fort les peuples autochtones mais par
contre le dollar
la nomination comme la personne marina
sur cette faille clandestins guy
herbulot des gens qui protège et la maja
nue donc il avait toujours un point en
ligne aux sables agriculture et les
faibles rendements dans les combats
c'est très plaisant de l'essence les
gens s'entendent exécuté avec mon solo
et un c'est tout a changé dans le sens
où la funai winfrey ils sont
respectivement les discussions
médiatique responsable pour régler les
problèmes fonciers les conflits fonciers
et la faune en effet la profession des
réserves indigènes
oui bon ça l'a avoué à la fête symbolise
ce pas les gens avec la compétence
technique connaît les pertes sont déjà
liés aux rues de là un gros business
donc là les salaires et les mouvements
sociaux
ils ont commencé mais ceux qui on voit
maintenant c'est vraiment une façon de
vous laisser les pays à la disposition
nous fait pas le plein c'est pour
rappeler canada et la liaison portable
avec ce qu'il veut en amazonie
spécialement les clubbers qui n'est pas
de pas connecté avec l'aide envoyée pour
combattre la casse devait ou du québec
là elle nous fait six ans shepy par
andrew de fonds financiers des terrains
en amazonie doxa ait de la pression de
la déforestation et ça met du sien la
pression sur les francophones
ils ce sont des gardiens de la forêt
alors oui on a toujours un pragmatique
entre les développements du pays le
développement économique et la
préservation c'est toujours difficile d
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le choc brésil et
même fiche je trouve qu'il ya des
solutions à cet égard restent difficiles
au niveau politique de l'espoir le
chemin mais avec mon sonar ou le message
était clair amazonie c'est un espace où
il manque le développement il est
développement qu'on veut laisser la
chance aux gens c'est la seule question
maintenant d'alice pour vous oui en fait
je veux savoir madame alexandra des
secondes qui on sait que la forêt brûle
c'est un phénomène des fois normal de
foi paranormal et puis on il est très
très difficile d'établir les
responsabilités
j'ai un plan purement juridique pensez
vous qu'il y à une meilleure façon de
trouver une solution à ce problème là
sur le plan juridique comment
contraindre différentes parties à
observer les règles environnementales
sur ce plan exactement ça un chemin que
ça m'étonne et ça me bouleverse
on a de plaisanter gens qui disaient
qu'il fallait faire on a tout les outils
technologiques
on a des sacs et on a des gens est
normalement capables et compétents ou
maxi l'institut est généralement fait ce
genre de jeu pavail ibama
je me suis posé mon pas encore droit et
j'ai travaillé aussi avec des preuves du
port à l'époque au mato grosso au brésil
l'inde l'une des provinces au brésil où
les feux attaque en ce moment en dépit
des anormalités c'est trop et il aidera
que partout l'avis de la cre
c'est qu'elles vivent dans ces moments
si déjà on étire ce qu'est un conseil
physiquement où sont les points où la
forêt mur 12 ça fait deux décennies les
fans brésiliens a choisi de la faire
agir
c'est une décision politique
déforestation de la forêt amazonienne
ses fans activement
cependant ce serait ça normal c'est un
projet de développement devait lui qui
aimait prise par conservation de forêts
et de ses fans fassions des points
communs où seule la dynamique on doit se
développer
donc au lieu d'investir dans les
énergies renouvelables ou lyon divertir
dans les parodies au brésil à sao paulo
et et moi je viens je fais mon doctorat
là bas c'est une université extrêmement
importante
elles étaient deux zones dans l'enfance
vers 16 heures au pied vous ne devez
plus importantes universités au monde
avec des obligations de la recherche et
au lieu d'investir dans les cheminées
les chaires de recherche pour trouver
des solutions ou développeur et et de la
façon et tendre l'allégeance les gars de
leur chemin trim actifs ont choisi
encore une façon très ancienne que celle
avant de commander commandes et ils se
lassent ceux des produits primaires cela
soit ya ses droits face aux détails
c'est pourtant ce que le maire
la réussite de ski paloma brûle de vous
poser une question ça au changement non
en fait je me demandais comment les
citoyens peuvent agir peuvent avoir une
incidence sur la solution à ce problème
parce que souvent on se pose la question
parce qu'on a on voit les problèmes de
réglages et on sait pourquoi faire à
notre échelle
donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez que les
canadiens aient encore latino américains
ou même les gens du monde peuvent faire
pour que ça change
je pense que en tant que canadiens on
doit interpeller les gouvernements
canadiens à l'égard des investissements
que la caisse de dépôt du québec fait en
amazonie en tant que québécois et
québécoises jambut et s'asseoir ici
peuvent alors de notre société
les brûlures et les forêts pour faire de
produits et avoir d'abord être fait jean
de la
ça comme français en valeur en même
temps les gouvernements du canada
là aussi il doit toute façon de
réglementer l'activité de l'industrie
minière ou faire des dégâts importants
aux deux villes qui nous est issu de la
région qui est vrai et ciblées pour la
conservation pour la préservation et non
pour l'exploration et poulet façon
générale alors un pacte citoyenne et
citoyen je pense et il faut se faire un
temps et pour se faire entendre il faut
sortir de l'enfer de l'individuel ou
s'impliquer s'impliquer d'une façon ce
soit dans le jeu soit dans les
manifestations que ce soit en
adolescence est élu il faut faire
quelque chose c'est sûr et certain et je
ne crois pas dans une solution magique
avec un coup de baguette magique j'ai
pas vraiment dans une panoplie une
diversifie d'engagement dont on doit on
garder les outils juridiques
il ya des juristes en ce moment même au
brésil et je fais partie qui ont envie
en action contre bon scénario pour un
est possible c'est un crime contre
l'humanité c'est en train de se passer
en amazonie hebrew notre culture mais
surtout en tant que citoyen et citoyenne
pour une fois il faut comprendre que les
peuples autochtones change effectivement
les
groupe en ce moment que bon leur moyen
de vie à un outil de préservation de la
forêt donc donné d'instructions pour
votre le brésil c'est préserver
l'amazonie et ces gens là ils se font
exécuter
ils seront suivis d'une façon
systématique au brésil
et ils sont déçus des ventes du génocide
colonial
ils sont là encore je dirai donnez des
soutiens pour votre docteur ce soit
financier que ça soit pas des
engagements ça soit d'une façon de
consommer de la viande au consommer de
la soyez en train de s'enfuir et de la
loi galland
je pense que ça c'est des gens à
commettre de wolski vous êtes
probablement très loin d'être élu
éventuellement parce que vous répondez
aux questions quand vous pose une
question vous y répondez jusqu'au bout
fantastique
on aimerait ça vous garder avec nous
pendant un bon petit bout de temps mais
l'émission elle couvre plus rapidement
que nous alors merci beaucoup de nous
avoir apporté vos réflexions là dessus
aujourd'hui de voir que vous remercie
savoir que vous remercier l'excellent
travail
merci bonne journée m alexandra dévoue
le ski avocate en droit environnementaux
pour la rejoindre il faut aller au
département des sciences juridiques
université du québec à montréal
c'est intéressant ce que maître disait
parce que tel au bas mot si on en est à
6 une à côté de l'autre on avait la même
discussion on mange quoi
deux sujets problématiques qu'on brésil
le boeuf on va en manger moins donc là
on se retrouve un peu mais je prends un
coin je crois qu'une des choses qu'on
peut faire et de discuter de ça avec ma
fille ce matin c'est drôle qu'on en
parle parce que j'ai lu expliquer un peu
l'incidence qui peuvent avoir les
cultures de soja souriant dans la
maçonnerie justement de ce qui se passe
en amazonie pile m'expliquer mais nous
on penser parce qu'elle fait partie du
comité environnemental de son école
blablabla elles mangent de moins en
moins de bien d'être ce jeudi je pense
qu'il faut équilibrer parce qu'on ne
peut pas manger trop ddc ya trop de
biens non plus
donc il faut faire des petits pas par-ci
par-là alimentaire ça parce que j'ai
entendu des gens a subi 6 s exprimer à
ce niveau là il y avait posé sa main
suivent un hôpital être le guide du camp
vont pas réussir à être
environnementalement responsable donc il
faut se poser des questions mais
équilibrer notre alimentation au moins
écoutés on est prêt pour le deuxième
tour de boules 30 bull à perdre q vous
avez déjà tous perdu vos propres vingt
premières bolia semboules à perdre dans
l'émission j'aime ça comment vous nous
le rappeler à tout bout de champ j'ai du
plaisir de rien du tout le baril s'est
ainsi répétée alors on présente la
question à l'écran d'accord et on a
parlé beaucoup des forêts des autres
d'amazonie et cetera je vous demandais
quel pourcentage du territoire au canada
est officiellement protégés contre le
développement humain ça se passerait pas
comme ça au canada par exemple ce qui se
passe mais lorsqu'on fait des
projections ou des protéines à main en
ce moment même alors est ce que ca on
protège en ce moment de tout
développement humain c'est 10%
est ce que ces bébés 20% est-ce que
c'est 30 % du territoire canadien qui
est protégé ou d aucune de ces réponses
quel pourcentage du territoire au canada
et aux nombreux jaillissent à quelques
pas réalité
ah ouais j'irai avec la réponse d aucune
de ses rivaux qu'est-ce que vous iriez à
la place au pif
je dirais entre eux 15 sont 15% ou
trancher entre a et b vous feriez un
appel mais ça serait au milieu alors
dépôt alice maryse même j'irai avec 20
pour ça parce que je me dis que
peut-être qu'on a on projette que d'ici
quelques années
aller vers le 30 mai qu'on a des bas on
a dépassé la barre des 10 d'accord 30%
de gta iii canaliser ce serait au delà
de 3 millions de kilomètres carrés c'est
l'équivalent finalement il n'y a rien de
méprisant grande partie
le territoire canadien qui n'est pas
habitée c'est vrai donc on peut protéger
ça comme ça coûte rien c'est sa famille
qui peut être exploité dix n 10 pour ça
disent optimistes
excusez moi mais 10% ça serait déjà au
delà d'un million de kilomètres carrés
de moins
je dois demander pas mal on regarde
quelle est la bonne réponse ensemble les
astérix on apparaître sous la lettre e
très vite les doigts est-ce que ça oui
voilà c'est 30 % quand même ses marines
et non non non ben moi j'ai dix ans
j'étais comme ouais bah ya une petite
erreur là dedans
même si c'est pas 30 pour ça c'est
attendez moi s'est dit pour sa gamme
oui c'est légal les astérix
la régie est très positive dont on parle
de de protection allant gagner mais j'ai
gagné je suis surpris c'est un peu
triste en même temps parce que j'étais
pensé ne pas être assez finalement
jamais reste que je trouve intéressant
c'est ce qui se passe là bas c'est qu'on
dit que les compagnies elle apparaît des
compagnies minières canadiennes
il ya aussi un problème au canada par
rapport au travail des compagnies
minières canadiennes sur le canadien
dans la mesure où par exemple si on
découvrait je pense vous avez une ferme
vous avez une ferme accord non les
présentations des sang et or quelqu'un
découvre quête de l'or en dessous vient
du pétrole ben si vous n'avez pas le
choix il va falloir laisser rentrer la
compagnie pourra exploiter le sous-sol
il n'y a pas le droit vraiment vraiment
inscrit en dessous faudra négocier mais
c'est la compagnie quel goût du gros
bout du bâton
car en fait les lois
il protège dent malade est propriétaire
dans le cadre d'un désir d'une compagnie
minière de venir faire des affaires vous
êtes moins protégées que dans le cas par
exemple de ward marquer directement en
déchets vous la ouvrir mon nouveau
magasin c'est différent de ce qui amène
des à l'occasion d'une expropriation et
voilà ces grands mots malartic en
abitibi je le vois comment ça a été
exproprié les gens ont été expropriés
bien des déplacés pour faire un grand
trou pour aller chercher des leurs donc
l'histoire se joue et beaucoup de ça au
canada alors c'est un set à voir ce
qu'avait temps avait il n'y a pas de
danger quelques grosses compagnies
viennent creuser ou à votre sol mais la
crise 53 ou la cité des potiers
seulement 10 % du territoire est protégé
c'est la leçon de la base du cours
aujourd'hui j'ai quelque chose à vous
proposer
j'aime bien ça moi lagaf' j'aurai les
sexuelle compliquer les choses la pessah
quatre postes comme un journal poste
pour le poste oui quatre postes entrevue
skype temps plein sont chargés nord avec
skype c'est après l'entrevue skype c'est
ce que j'essaie de dire bon voilà je
vous présente ce si ce sont les
reportages que vous fait regarder sur la
page d'accueil de tam-tam canada cette
semaine pour approfondir cette question
on parle bien sûr de ce qui a été
discuté par les grands leaders pour
protéger l'amazonie cette fin de semaine
lors du g7
on parle évidemment du grand bolzano et
on essaie de voir qui est il et et
qu'est ce qui le fait avancer l'intérêt
ce en tout temps au jeu revient voilà on
va écouter c'est un quelque chose
produit par marie-jo 27 semaines
belle image maryse un cheval tout seul
sur un fond c'est une île déserte
ouais alors c'est vous qui avez fait ça
cette semaine oui mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous savez que ya
un spécialiste ici je vois ce que
peut-être madame connaît qu'on
interviewe et qui marqua michel nicolle
il faut savoir que les faire les
annonces et tous les ans il ya des
années sont pires que d'autres
évidemment pendant quelques années entre
les rôles de 1000 et 2000 christ est
vraiment eu un pic de furnes raison qui
avait décru uniquement avec le
gouvernement lula et j'ai vraiment ils
n'ont évidemment avec la vidéo on voit
bien il ya là une recrudescence de ces
activités
tout simplement parce qu'on aimait son
cul libre cours aux producteurs
d'étendre leurs surfaces sur lesquelles
ils vont planter du soja ou bien faire
mais peut-être l'ordre alors qu'il
savait que le déduit la socam ce n'est
pas dans le pire de la saison lui furent
on disait que le brésil c'est purement
blatter mais en fait un poumon sa
recherche co2 donc il faudra pas qu'on
utilise le mouvement il était en
entrevue à mary jo à rdi et il a tout
bien expliquer ça est ce qu'il
expliquait aussi c'est que les arbres on
les abat angeles sachet est là après on
veut et pour beaucoup de gens là bas qui
n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent c'est une
façon de s'approprier une terre donc
j'imagine que ça la route d'une certaine
façon vous permettre à des gens parce
que pas seulement des grandes
entreprises qui font ce métier là mais
aussi des petits producteurs donc
écouter un peu politique populiste
d'aller vers le peuple de permettre à ce
que des gens puisque c'était exactement
c'est comme une baisse d'impôts aux
états unis pour les pauvres
ce serait ça ce sera l'équivalent sauf
qu'il faut faire un peu d'argent pour
pouvoir en cas d'accord il ya du social
qui se crashe l'intérieur quelque part
oui tout à fait je voudrais vous
présenter une image ou une série d'image
d'accord vous avez besoin de ça pour le
prochain test de la console alors faut
bien alors je vous présente ces images
en vous disant qu' il ya présentement on
va parler de la foire et brian magee
je vous demandais si vous reconnaissez
cette forêt se veut me décrire ce à quoi
ça ressemble une forêt boréale au canada
où est-ce que c'est par exemple qui est
qu'ils se sentent attaque beaucoup les
qualifs l'air moite faye
voilà très bonne définition ensuite
dévasté ce pas ouais y en a beaucoup et
dans les prairies
ouais mais plus au nord parce que les
vrais risques a fait appel à la notion
de deux de mes chiens oui mais ça veut
pas dire qu'à pas des prairies à
l'intérieur des forêts boréales
ça c'est ce dont je sais pas pourquoi je
pars à rire alors ça coûte beaucoup de
territoires canadiens d'accord je peux
peut-être vous donner un petit indice
parce que je pouvais essayer de vous
aider il y en a qu'un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui ont perdu des boules
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas peur non mais je
n'ai je pu nous le goût de la table
voilà moi j'étais toujours assis à
l'arrière en place le tél 15
non c'est pas vrai du tout menacé à la
vente je peux pas dire parce que sinon
les gens se seraient jaloux encore
aujourd'hui alors rossi 3e tour d'un
grosse boule 50 boules à perdre voici la
question laquelle de ces forêts la plus
vaste en vérité laquelle de ces forêts
la plus vaste
est-ce que c'est à l'amazonie est ce que
ces bébés la forêt boréale canadienne à
os que c'est c'est à attendait là est ce
que c'est c'est la forêt boréale rue ce
qu'on appelle aussi la taïga n'a pas
hésité à l'amazonie mais la russe est ce
qu'on parle du rsa des anciennes terres
ou de la nouvelle russie n'en parle de
la russie actuelle mois celle amazonie
la masoni pour alice un match est
peut-être me tromper mais je vais aller
avec la forêt boréale russe faire
différent tu apprennes la forêt boréale
50 boules ap bah moi je n'ai pas alors
j'ai à faire
j'annonce pas le nom de la gagnante ou
des gagnants je sais pas on va regarder
la réponse maintenant avec l'ordinateur
de bord ben qu'est ce que ça dit maïs a
gagné
non c'est au oui la forêt boréale russe
tout à fait alors je rappelle à 50 et à
l'enap et retard à dulles
alors qu'on est égal non
la bonne réponse qui a répondu c'est que
c'est maryse marché barry sky magazine
70 la couronne comme bull la provence où
maryse donc elle a gâché la chance de
conserver 50 boules marie alice a tout
perdu
où aller moi j'ai perdu 50 noms ont
perdu dans tous les cas il ya deux
bagnoles
wang a gagné plus d'argent que moi alors
un monsieur
c'est à gagner 60 millions de dollars et
la joue et l'extra avec deux dollars de
plus il a attendu 10 mois avant d'aller
chercher son argent pour réfléchir
exactement qu'est ce que je risque ma
vie n'était même pas au courant alors
imaginez pas de secret c'est une belle
image la semaine
oui tout à fait mais non c'est pas celle
là qu'on a sélectionné pour aujourd'hui
alors on à maïs trop qui nous fait
entendre le thème c'est le double thème
de notre image de la semaine je répond
par oui ou par non y'a rien à perdre a
rien à gagner sinon quelle est l'image
de la semaine cette semaine le mois
dernier si vous voulez le mois dernier
moins de goût mais non on parle de la
semaine mais la forêt qui brûle la forêt
qui brûle la forêt qui brûle à la
semaine dernière
et se poursuit cette semaine qui s'est
passé cette semaine oh il ya eu une
annonce concernant le libère 2019-2020
que ça va être moins de neige et froid
on continue j'ai pas moins des
tergiversations d'un touch r j'aime pas
les auteurs oui autour de la question de
l'avortement non c'est trop sérieux
bah moi c'est essentiellement la forêt
la forêt qui brûle et qui n'en est pas
là mais ça se passe dans la forêt c'est
sûr ouais ça se passe dans la forêt je
vous amène un peu ça se passe dans la
forêt bon à la frontière de l'alaska et
de la colombie britannique et sa main ça
pourrait être l'histoire des saumons qui
dieu coincé mais ça c'est une joie qui a
commencé il ya quelqu'un à brac donc le
nom un peu plus d'aidé cela je travaille
à un animal là-dedans annonce oui et
c'est lorsque s'est fait donner des
timbits oui exactement
et j'ai les mêmes images que vous nous
racontez l'histoire mais monsieur vous
qu'à donner à manger des timbits parce
qu'on sait tous c'est quoi de timbits et
très canadien mais s'est expliqué sur
les trompettes messagerie mais parce que
quand on fait des bergues ya toujours un
trou d'air que je retrouve alors la pac
et le milieu bon la récupère on l'a fait
cuire et sa folie tmdc fait partie
burton c'est une chaîne comme seul
équivalent du starbucks tendre au pays
c'est notre site a été racheté par des
intérêts de rites merci pour la visite
gratuite
ouais la publicité gratuite pour une
meilleure sélection père mais il ya une
contravention pour avoir fait sa part et
surtout pas dé l'as du secret ça combien
la contrebasse su combien ce trajet tout
y est me souviens pu mais ceci n'est pas
sucré c'est pas secret
j'ai les médias à jay leno la série j'ai
lancé à chypre comme ça donc je vais
vous êtes la juge dans le cas vous avez
décidé de me lancer du millénaire mais
il croyait que c'était plutôt
sympathique de donner un mondial s'est
ramassé avec une sacrée en main mais ça
c'est un problème en nourrir les la
faune avec des trucs comme ça
ce qui fait que deviennent des pandas
unis perdent leur instinct c'est un
bijou
il faut savoir quand j'étais guide
sommes au mont royal ici j'étais tout
cas tu risques
et puis on nous dit c'est même dangereux
de faire ça il faut vraiment pas donner
à manger aux animaux sauvages du tout
c'est dangereux
ce n'est pas bon pour la santé oui c'est
ça alors là j'ai besoin de deux
volontaires qui est ce que j'ai eu 9
d'abord savoir par quel hasard mon pote
portail est volontaire mais j'avais ça
c'est nouveau cette semaine j'ai pas de
thème musical mais mon imagination
continue de courir vous avez alors j'ai
appelé ça le jeu de la meilleure
présentation alors la meilleure
présentation pourquoi est ce que vous le
jeu de la meilleure présentation pour
une présentation pas ce à quoi vous
présenter une vidéo que je vais vous
donner je vous donnais le dessus de la
vidéo
allez voir les images apparaît et vous
fait les présentations c'est un concours
d'art dramatique c'est d'improvisation
c'est bon c'est très bon pour le mois et
c'est le celui ou celle ci n'est pas
votre cas c'est celle qui ferait on a
fait des représentations on va le savoir
s'est passé j'ai besoin de volontaires
[Musique]
lever la main tout ça en jette à l'eau
c'est quoi complet moi je me jette à
l'eau avec cela alors no 2 vera drake
solidaire solidarité centre gauche je
crois qu'ils maime en quelques minutes à
notre émission c'est à dire que le bon
tu es passé nous en avait j'espère
poursuivre jusqu'au bout ça dure pas
longtemps notre première vidéo
alors c'est aller ce qui va nous
présenter la vidéo donc on appelle ça
nos balades au comment écouter nos
balades au c'ur merci
c'est tout nouveau comme service a fait
quelques mots quelques semaines et la
vidéo apparaît l'instant bon ben voilà
pour écouter nos balades au oui sur
notre application
et puis il faut cliquer sur une vidéo de
notre choix
par exemple on a cette histoire
concernant les élections générales au
canada on clique dessus en l'écoutant
quelques minutes en quelques secondes
et puis on peut donner des commentaires
on peut émettre des idées pour nous
permettre d'améliorer l'écoutent et la
présentation des informations sur notre
site
radio canada international en ce moment
est en quête de nouveautés parce qu'il
est question d'attirer plus de lecteurs
et plus d'auditeurs et donc vos
impressions votre âge en comble et donc
voilà le public est appelé à interagir
avec nous pour nous aiguiller sur la
meilleure façon d'améliorer notre site
et notre présentation merad en terre non
c'est pas ça comme ça je ne fais pas
compétition madame banon mais cette
affaire et qu'elle a dû tout ce temps
ouais ça va durer qu'elle veut pas des
images volées
c'est maintenant aux mavs interrompue
moi je ne perdrai pas lasser eh ben ça
parce que la deuxième vidéo vous nous
expliquer ça s'appelle radio canada
international
notre nouvelle application on roule et
c'est notre dernière vidéo de la journée
comment c'est quoi exactement cette
application encore là ouais on vous
écoute bon ben notre nouvelle
application comme vous pouvez le voir
eh ben c'est une nouveauté dans 5
langues différentes
donc là dedans vous avez des émissions
en français en anglais en espagnol en
arabe
et c'est l'actualité et l'actualité
quotidienne
vous pouvez suivre sur votre téléphone
en baladodiffusion et donc franchement
c'est des informations actuelles qui
sont vraiment mises à jour sur une base
quotidienne et donc vous avez des
informations qui couvre l'ensemble du
canada parce que le but pour nous c'est
de faire
connaître le canada à l'international
sur le plan politique économique et
sociale c'est de faire redécouvrir le
canada dans toute son entièreté avec des
informations concernant différents
fichiers la voilà c'est ça les vous
allez me remplacer la semaine chercher à
vous avez du métier faut que ça qu'à la
télévision
tu habites eu à remplir quand vous alors
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
je retiens cette idée du jeu de la fin
d'émission bon on choisira cami ferrat
la prochaine foire et on n'évitera pas à
lire merci pour cette semaine de vous
avoir reçu ici dans mon studio la
semaine prochaine tout le monde
[Musique]